je suis évidemment très heureux très
honoré
j'exprime toute ma great put julie tout
d'abord et j'exprime aussi mes
félicitations et mes pensées
tous les candidats qui auraient pu aussi
avoir ses livres ce prix est pour qui
pour des raisons très différentes
voulait vraiment lourd est méritée
c'est très spécial pour moi évidemment
je pense à ma famille je pense à tous
les professeurs qui m'ont formé
je pense le maître m'a même être en
littérature qui sont nombreux et que je
ne veux pas citer ici je pense à mes
éditeurs qui sont avec moi un philippe
rey évidemment et céline certes des
éditions du msan du sénégal puisque
c'est une co édition
pour le reste je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'académie goncourt
envoie un signal très fort je pense
à beaucoup de gens
d'abord au milieu littéraire français il
y demande mais à tous les milieux
littéraires de l'espace francophone et
je pense que c'est important de le dire
je ne voudrais pas du tout qu'on pensait
que cette récompense
relève de quelque chose d'exceptionnel
un régime d'exceptionnalité ce n'est pas
une saveur confie un écrivain africain
c'est pas parce qu'il est africain qu'il
abuse j'espère j'espère vraiment que
c'est parce que d'abord il y à un livre
qui à la base de tout cela mais je
videmment je n'ignore pas les questions
politiques qu'il peut y avoir derrière
une récompense semblable et je remercie
vraiment le jury d'avoir eu ces
gestes-là cette pensée là qui n'est pas
en reste de faveur qui en geste
littéraire mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'à partir de l'espace littéraire
on peut penser des questions le
politique qu'il y ait maintenant à
l'espace francophone de soissons plus
générale au sein duquel la france figure
au sein duquel le sénégal figure au sein
du teil haïti figurent ceux du cal
beaucoup de pays figure mais une fois
que j'ai dit tout cela j'espère surtout
que c'est d'abord une délicat nature il
s'agit ici au sens le plus beau et le
plus noble du terme donc fui réserve
pour cela